hello everyone and welcome to a most
interesting game from round one of the
Prague chess festival the Masters
edition it's a David navara the number
one check player versus young feast of
Duda the number one poll is Grand Master
and Duda is also the at the top seed in
the tournament here it's a 10 player
round robin here are the players who
will be competing mostly young players
so let's just check it out Neil's grand
alias this is the first round green
delicious versus Hari Krishna well it is
a future versus Marcos de rigueur Vicki
I need to go sorry Nikita Whitaker vs.
Antony Harvey did Santos who is ready
for Samuel chantant and on board five
well it's not actually bought five but
David Navarro versus young fish to the
Duda so we're gonna be checking out some
of the games from this tournament and
this being organized by Novy Bor chess
club also from Prague and the the time
format is 19 minutes per player for the
first 40 moves then you are granted an
additional half an hour and of course 30
seconds increment starting from move 1
so without further ado let's check it
out
so Navarro opens with E for Duda replies
with c5 we have the Sicilian defense
Knight to f3 d6 and d4 so nothing
nothing out of the ordinary here Knight
to f6 Knight c3 with a6
Duda goes for the night or defense and
then now h3 or a very popular idea did
the so-called Adams attacked we have e 6
and now as Y prepared g4 we have g4 now
preparing to dislodge the night with g5
black prevents this with h6 and now
Bishop to g2 are continuing development
we have Knight to c6 and Bishop to e3 so
very natural development by both sides
Bishop to e7 and now f4 and here black
moves the knight doesn't allow g5 to
come with an attack on the night so
Knight d7 now preparing to push g5 which
which which will actually be a novelty
in this game and here navara decides
that he does not want the capture on c6
and he does not want to keep the tension
so he he goes back knife to f3 and the
night will now also support the the g5
square and there is one game
well there are several games I believe
eight games in the database that reach
this exact same position but in all of
them beef I was played and it's
interesting even navara had this exact
same position only when where he was
playing the black pieces in 2017 in the
European Championship in Batumi in
Georgia he played against whatõs and the
game ended in a draw but here do that
goes for g5 and this is now a new move
so as of move 11 we have a completely
new game so let's see what happens here
with Knight to e2 by Navarro he wants
the riemann over denied over to g3 from
where he will have access at the age 5
but also to support efore from there so
G captures on f4 Bishop captures an f4
now putting pressure on d6 with the
Queen and the bishop
Knight to e5 now blocking this and here
Knight captures any v with Knight
captures on e5 and now this Knight the
g3 maneuver and here okay you have a lot
of a lot of ideas with white you do have
already three point islands but black
also has three point islands but here
with the white King still being in the
center of the board it's a bit more
loose the black King has a lot of
defensive pawns around here so here you
could consider castling kingside you
could play maybe Queen d2 Castle
queenside but the Duda goes Queen to b6
he says I'm pressuring the b2 pawn and
you are not castling kingside at least
not for the moment and here
Navarre decides to give up the bishop
pair and eliminate this knight and a
mess of a black's pawn structure a
little bit but as you'll see it will not
be all that important in this game but
should capture 75 we have D captures on
e5 and now Queen to f3 developing the
Queen also preparing to Castle queenside
but also asking black we are we may be
interested in in a nice B to pawn and if
du decides to capture then you can
Castle kingside black will also Castle
kingside and then we have a well a
fairly crazy game here with the knight
now being able to come to h5 to pressure
f6 it's gonna be so black will be okay
he does have the best repair but it's
gonna be very interesting
so instead do the first play Bishop to
g5 he says for the moment you're not
castling kingside or Queen side so what
do you play here first
h4 now asking what do you want to do
with the bishop if you move back
I'll just Castle queenside and I'm gonna
I'm gonna play this very enjoyable game
so do that decides that now it's time to
trade Queens we have Quinta III with
check Queen captures with Bishop
captures now again preventing the Castle
kingside or Queen side as you guard both
c1 in g1 but now King Teti - now you
push away the bishop and your rooks are
now free to enter the game so here Duda
goes back Bishop to a7 and the now rook
a to d1 a nice a nice open file for the
rook Bishop to d7 now preparing to bring
the rook into the game also to develop
the Bishop King f3
and now comes King to e7 connecting
rooks mobilizing your king and now rook
the h2 preparing to move the bishop most
likely to h3 maybe f1 in some lines and
then bring the rook over to d2 nicely
double rooks along the D file and then
put pressure under well for the moment
as the bishop is on d7 but now rook H to
g8 here Duda says that okay maybe your
Jeep on a g4 point is a little bit weak
I'm controlling g5 so maybe maybe I'm
gonna go rook to g6 bringing the other
look over to g8 and create some threats
along the Kings side so Bishop to h3
already adding another defensive
strategy for pawn but mostly preparing
this rook to come at to the open D file
and now Bishop to a4 and now this is a a
very interesting move you could block
with b3 b3 seems like that seems like a
very natural move to play but maybe
because black has the bishop pair maybe
you don't want to commit your pawns to
any any squares just yet so for the
moment rook eh the d2 saying that
there's still no need to actually guard
the pawn I can always play b3 and I I do
have some nice pressure along the D file
for the moment the bishop guards d7 so
that's not
issue but here Duda has a most
interesting move so even feel free to
pause the video what would you play here
well I'll give you a couple of seconds
so for those who were well not able to
do it but who found to do this idea
congratulations on being such an
excellent endgame player and for those
who just want to enjoy the show
a good idea is rook g6 and you just go
after the g4 pawn that's that's a good
idea but do that plays an even better
one rook a to c8 and now you've added
another attacker to the seat upon which
is of course very important but now the
problem is now the time for b3 is too
late because of rook the c3 check now
the King cannot move from the defense of
the night you block with the rook and
then now you play rook captures and see
- that's doulas idea because if you
capture the bishop then a rook to f2 is
checkmate the bishop nicely guards the
rook and the King has nowhere to go so
very very very strong move here this
rook 8 the c8 so here we have Bishop
back to f1 saying okay I'm I don't mind
you can have this c2 pawn here and
indeed black doesn't really gain all
that much for example if Brooke captures
you're just gonna trade here captures
captures you bring the rook to c1 attack
the bishop the ship moves and now just
rook the c7 check King f6 and now you
pick up the b7 pawn you're also
attacking the a6 pawn the bishop so not
much to be done here from black on the
other hand if you capture with the
bishop it's not not all that all that
much better sorry after Bishop to f1 if
you capture with the bishop it's a roof
to d7 check you no longer control the d7
Square from there King f8 and now rook
to d2 you just attack the bishop and now
pretty much you will get your pawn back
you will either capture b7 or even if
you don't if somehow you defend it or
play some other move let's say route g6
are you you can play even I move like
bishop characters in a sex where if you
capture then you lose the bishop on e7
and and so on so after Bishop to f1 look
the g6 instead by Duda showing his true
intention not caring about the c2 pawn
now Duda is coming after the player
kingside so night the h5 here and now
again not not going for right away but
first Bishop to d4 he says okay now you
can never use the the open D file my
dark square bishop is nicely placed here
and you cannot kick it away from there
with C 3 because the rook on d1 hangs so
and what to do you play here you could
go for b3 let's say Bishop e7 and c4
but again although you've you you no
longer have to worry about the C pawn
and you do kind of have a nice structure
here
you're never getting rid of this dark
square bishop here you have a light
square bishop and two rooks and this is
just two stronger piece this rook can
now come to g8 pressure this and it will
be pretty much a one-sided game so after
Bishop d4 we have Bishop to d3
now again defending this in adding more
protection to d4 pawn but basically this
bishop is now pretending to be a point
so Duda continues with his plan rooks
eat the g8 he goes after g4 but now rook
g2 and it's not it doesn't really work
since the rook is only guarded by the
king so Duda executes f5 here and it's a
very strong move because you cannot
capture sorry you cannot capture with
the Jeep on if you capture with the e
pawn which is what happened in the game
then of course Bishop the c6 check this
happens and now you could try and keep
your keep your well quality keep your
exchange for example with Bishop c4 but
after characters captures and rook
captures and g4 with check you will have
a nice trade here and Daniel it's a king
b3 you will capture on f5 black is
already up upon but White's white rook
is pretty much useless this is under
attack this is under attack it will just
be a complete domination by black so
after Bishop to c6 check my Duda we have
King 2 e 2 and now comes just not
grabbing this if you grab this then F
characters and g6 and the white will be
very happy
so after King e2 with he captures on f5
and the now comes Knight to g3
again you cannot capture so it doesn't
really it doesn't really do anything for
you and
your rook is still under attack but you
cannot you cannot prevent everything if
you if you move the rook yes you could
try that but then rookie actress Angie
for and it's just very very painful so
here
Knights the g3 was played by Navarro
going for this Knight captures on a five
width check but do this calculates
precisely he plays Bishop characters in
g2 grabs the rook with Knight captures
on f5 with check King f6 and the now
Knight captures on d4 saying that okay
now if you capture now I can capture on
g6 but to do that just plays rook
captures on g4 and now again what do you
play here there really aren't all that
many squares for tonight the problem is
if you move the knight let's say Knight
B 3 E 4 is extremely strong because now
you have the F 3 square guarded for your
bishop so after Bishop moves yes you
attack the rug but just Bishop to f3
check King III now you can capture here
and it's a full rook because after
characters you will recapture like this
and now you are up a whole rook even
after which the King captures on e4 but
after Luke characters in g4 Knight the
f5 was played but it's not it's not any
better Duda continued in the same
fashion
efore now the knight is no longer
guarded Knight captures in h6 yes you
are attacking both of the rooks but here
just bishop you could capture with
charities to sufficient but just Bishop
to f3 check and it was in this position
that David Navarro resigned the game as
well there is nothing more to be done
here
after King to e3 you will capture the
rook let's see like that and even yes
this will come with check but again you
are up after all is said and done you
are up a whole rook so now after Bishop
to f3 Navarro resigned and a brilliant
victory for a young sister Duda with the
black pieces or also a very important
one we're not going to show the
standings just yet as some other
interesting games happen to which I will
try to show we will see how many I will
be able to show from round 1 and then
we're gonna check out the standings so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Klaus møller
Nielsen a young Glen Glen coffin Stein
Thomas and Thomas cashmere ski for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check too on my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
very nice practice festival masters
edition and of course continuing the
Paul Morphy saga so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day